what we have depicted here is a signal
transduction pathway that gets started
with the cholera toxin and we've talked
about signal transduction pathways in
other videos but it's really this idea
that you would have molecules outside of
the cell that would interact with
receptors on the surface of the cell
that would then create a whole chain
reaction of events that would cause that
cell to do something and so what's
happening here is if you were in the
unfortunate situation and this is not
something that you would wish on anyone
if they were to have the cholera
bacteria in their gut so let's say that
this is the cholera bacteria that
cholera bacteria in your intestines will
release the what we can call the cholera
toxin and here it's depicted in very
abstract fashion by a circle on top of a
triangle that's not what it actually
looks like it's a protein complex with
various protein subunits it's just drawn
this way so that we can think about this
triangle part interacting with this
receptor on the epithelial cell and so
what happens is this cholera toxin it
will interact with this ganglioside
receptor and you don't have to know the
details here really just the idea of
what's going on and then once it does
that when you see these arrows on these
transduction pathways you could view it
as that is going to activate the next
step or sometimes you might say might
promote the next step or make it more
likely to happen but what then happens
is is once this thing has interacted the
a part of the subunit goes in interacts
with a g protein you don't have to know
all the details here but g proteins are
something that you'll see in a lot of
signal transduction pathways there's not
just one g protein there's a whole
family of proteins called g proteins and
you can view them as molecular switches
they can get turned on and off based on
how they're interacting with other
molecules their conformation their shape
changes and so that might activate or
deactivate them but you can see you can
follow these arrows and you can see what
eventually happens and you don't have to
know every detail here eventually it
leads to adenylate cyclase then cyclic
amp then the protein kinase gets
involved but the end result from this
pathway is that you have these ions
being released from this epithelial cell
and with that that causes the water to
leave the cell and that's what causes
diarrhea so the toxin gets your gut
cells gets your intestinal cells to
start releasing water so then you're
going to have very very very bad
diarrhea
so that's the big picture but now we can
think about what might happen in certain
situations so if i were to ask you let's
say this epithelial cell somehow had a
mutation so its ganglioside receptor
does not interact well with the b
subunit here with the cholera toxin what
would happen then pause this video and
try to think about that
all right so for whatever reason this
epithelial cell had a
ganglioside receptor that was a little
bit different and it couldn't interact
as efficiently with the cholera toxin
well in that situation
this this activation would not be
happening or at least would not be
happening as efficiently and so someone
with that type of a ganglioside receptor
there might be some other negative side
effects but they actually would not get
as bad diarrhea from the cholera toxin
because this whole signal transduction
pathway would not be happening or would
not be happening as strong
now on the other hand it turns out that
there's molecules that can disrupt this
signal transduction pathway so what we
have right over here this is an opioid
receptor
and if it gets activated then it will
activate another g protein this one is
different than the one here but it's
part of that same family and when you
see this type of thing when you see a
line with this flat head instead of an
arrow that means it's inhibiting that
process so for example this opioid
receptor is receptive to a molecule
known as encephalin once again you don't
have to know that what you should know
is that okay you have this molecule
outside of the cell that can interact
with the opioid receptor which will then
activate a g protein and what's
interesting is that this g protein is
actually an inhibitor of this step right
over here and so if you have cholera and
the cholera toxins in your gut but you
also expose those epithelial cells to
encephalin well that might make the
diarrhea a little bit less bad because
if this gets disrupted or at least if it
gets inhibited then the rest of this
pathway will not happen or it will not
happen quite as strong
so that leads another question
if there was some mutation in the opioid
receptor here
so it wasn't as good at binding to
encephalin what would be the end result
so if your opioid receptor is somehow
not as receptive to encephalin well then
encephalin will not be as effective at
being able to stop this signal
transduction pathway because the
encephalin will not be able to bind with
that opioid receptor and so this
inhibition will not occur and so you
would just have the regular transduction
pathway from the cholera toxin occurring
which results in diarrhea so i'll leave
you there the big thing to appreciate is
when you see these pathways arrows you
can view as activation or they're
leading to the next step and these lines
with these flatheads this is about
inhibition and it's pretty typical to
see questions and especially if you're a
scientist you might construct these
pathways but you'll also get questions
on hey if there's a mutation on
something that is activating part of the
pathway what will happen and then the
pathway won't happen as much or maybe at
all and if there's a mutation in
something that inhibits the pathway what
would happen well if there's a mutation
that makes something that would
regularly inhibit a pathway less
functional then it won't be able to
inhibit the pathways much and so the
pathway will be less inhibited